ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Firebase
is Google's mobile and web
app development platform
and it offers many
useful cloud services.
So you might wonder, what is the
relationship between Firebase
and Google Cloud Platform?
Stick around and I'll
help you understand.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You may know Firebase
for all the features
it offers to enhance
your client app,
such as authentication,
analytics, crash reporting, AB
testing, or in-app messaging.
But Firebase also
has several options
to manage data and
business logic in the cloud
to help you build better apps.
This includes a No SQL
database, server-less functions,
on device and server
side machine learning
APIs, blob storage, and more.
Firebase is a wonderful
way for Android
and web developers to
leverage Google Cloud Services
without exposing them to all
the knobs and dials of GCP.
In fact, when you create
a Firebase project,
it is a GCP project
in every aspect.
Resource grouping, identity
management, and billing,
are all the same.
This gives you a great way
to start using some cloud
services before you
graduate into using GCP only
when you need to.
This is also
important to any user
interested in building a
mobile or web app on top
of an existing GCP
infrastructure.
While the look and feel of
the Firebase console and cloud
console are clearly different,
you can open the same project
with either one.
If you'd like to
open an existing GCP
project in the Firebase console
to add Firebase-specific
functionality, simply
select add a project
and click through
the few setup steps.
Once done, all the Firebase APIs
will be automatically enabled
in your project.
If you have an existing
Firebase project,
simply head over
to Cloud Console
and open it there
with its identifier.
You should see and
be able to manipulate
all of the project resources.
Finally, you want to be
careful about deleting projects
as deleting a Firebase
project deletes
the Google Cloud
projects as well and all
its contained resources.
So now that you know that
a Firebase project is also
GCP project, let's focus
on the three main products
that Firebase and
GCP have in common.
Cloud storage, a massively
scalable blob storage system,
Cloud Functions, a server-less
compute infrastructure
for event driven programming,
and Cloud Firestore,
a massively scalable
no SQL database.
These three GCP products
can be used in Firebase
with additional mobile SDKs,
as well as from the Firebase
CLI or command line interface.
We'll cover the first
one now and the other two
in the next video.
So make sure you
subscribe to this channel.
Cloud storage is a powerful,
yet simple to use blob
storage system.
And if you have not
heard of it, then you
should check out the short data
and storage overview video link
below.
Cloud console exposes the
full power of cloud storage
while the Firebase console
exposes those features that
are most likely to be relevant
to Firebase developers.
A typical use case for Firebase
developers using cloud storage
is when managing user
generated content.
This is where the Firebase
Android, iOS, web, Unity,
and c++ SDKs, make it easy
and yet secure to upload
and download objects such as
images straight from the app.
Similarly to GCP projects
using App Engine,
any new Firebase project comes
with a default cloud storage
bucket.
In most cases,
Firebase developers
also use this default
storage location
and does not need to
reference it by name.
Because of all the GCP
and Firebase commonalities
this causes so far, any
data stored in Cloud Storage
using Firebase can
be further access
and processed in
GCB and vise versa.
Imagine, for
instance, a Firebase
powered mobile applications
uploading pictures
to cloud storage.
It would be quite easy for
a Cloud Scheduler initiate
a task to resize, crop,
delete, or otherwise
manipulate all pictures
in this default bucket.
You can also feed these
files into other GCP big data
products such as BigQuery, data
flow, or even into our machine
learning products.
One thing that you
will want to note
is how bucket access control
is different and orthogonal.
Cloud IAM is used to control
access to buckets and objects
from GCP services.
On the other hand,
Firebase security rules
control access only
from mobile applications
that use the Firebase SDKs.
So there, you now know how
data stored in Cloud Storage
can be equally accessed
via a Firebase powered app
as well as you know from
your GCP hosted applications.
In the next episode, we'll
discuss the two remaining
products common to both
platforms, Cloud Functions
and Cloud Firestore.
Same project and
building infrastructure,
common cloud storage.
The two platforms
have a lot in common
and were conceived to nicely
complement one another.
It's time to get going with
Firebase or GCP or both.
Thanks for watching this video.
Please like, subscribe,
comment, share, and look forward
to more GCP Essentials videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]